what are the measures of human
intelligence and how do we measure it
everybody has an idea of what they mean
by intelligence
in the in the vernacular what i mean by
intelligence is just being smart how
well you reason how well you figure
things out what you do when you don't
know what to do
those are just
kind of everyday common sense
definitions of how people use the word
intelligence if you want to do research
on intelligence
measuring something that you can study
scientifically is a little trickier
and what almost all
researchers who study intelligence use
is the concept called the g factor
general intelligence
and that is what is common that is a
mental ability that is common to
virtually all tests
of mental abilities what's the origin of
the term g factor by the way it's such a
funny word for such a fundamental human
thing the general factor i really
started with charles spearman
and he noticed this is like a boy more
than a hundred years ago
he noticed
that
when you tested people with different
tests
all the tests were
correlated positively
and so he was looking at student exams
and things
and he invented the correlation
coefficient essentially
and he
when he used it to look at student
performance on various topics he found
they all the scores were correlated with
each other and they were all positive
correlations so he inferred from this
that there must be some common factor
that was irrespective of the content of
the test and positive correlation means
if you do well on on the first test
you're likely to do well in the second
test and presumably that holds for tests
across even disciplines so
not within subject but across subjects
so that's
where the general comes in some
something about general intelligence so
when you were talking about measuring
intelligence and
and trying to figure out
something difficult about this world and
how to solve the puzzles of this world
that means generally speaking not some
specific tests but across all tests
absolutely right and people get hung up
on this
uh because they said well what about the
ability to do x
isn't that
independent and they said i know
somebody who's very good at this but not
so good at this
this other thing yeah and so there are a
lot of examples like that but it's a
general tendency so
exceptions really don't disprove
you know your your everyday experience
is not the same as what the data
actually
show and your everyday experience when
you say oh i know someone who's good at
x but not so good at why that doesn't
contradict the statement of about a he's
not so good but he's not
the opposite it's not a it's not a
negative correlation
okay so we're not with our anecdotal
data
i know a guy is really good at
solving some kind of visual thing
that's not
sufficient for us to understand actually
the depths of that person's intelligence
so
how this idea of g factor
um
how much evidence is there
how strong you know given across the
decades that this idea has been around
how much has it been held up that there
is a universal
uh
sort of horsepower of intelligence
that's underneath all of it all the
different tests we do to try to get to
this thing
uh in in the depths of the human mind
that's a that's a universal stable
measure of a person's intelligence
you used a couple of words in there yeah
stable and
we have to be precise with words we're
hoping we can get away with being poetic
we can there's a lot about research in
general not just intelligence research
that is poetic
science has a phonetic aspect to it and
good scientists are are very intuitive
they're not just
hey these are the numbers you have to
kind of step back and see the big
picture when it comes to
uh intelligence
research you asked how well has this
general concept held up and i think i
can say
without fear of being empirically
contradicted
that it is the most replicated finding
in all of psychology now some cynics may
say well big deal psychology we all know
there's a replication crisis in
psychology and a lot of this stuff
doesn't replicate that's all true there
is no replication crisis when it comes
to studying the the existence of this
general factor let me tell you some
things about it it is it it looks like
it's universal in uh that you find it in
all cultures
the way you find it let's step back one
one step the way you find it is to give
a battery of mental tests
what battery you choose take a battery
of any mental test you want
give it to a large number of diverse
people
and you will be able to extract
statistically
the comment the commonality among all
those tests it's done by a technique
called factor analysis you
people
uh
think that's that this may be a
statistical artifact of some kind it is
not a statistical artifact
what is factual analysis factor analysis
is a way of looking at a big set of data
and look at the correlation among the
different test scores and then find
empirically the clusters of scores that
go together
and there are different factors so if
you have a bunch of mental tests there
may be a verbal factor there may be a
numerical factor there may be a visual
spatial factor but those factors have
variants in common with each other and
that is the common
uh that's what's common among all the
tests and that's what gets labeled the g
factor so if you give a diverse battery
of mental tests
and you extract a g factor from it that
factor usually accounts for around half
of the variance it's the single biggest
factor but it's not the only factor
but it is the most reliable it is the
most stable
and it seems
to be very much influenced by genetics
it's very hard to change the g factor
with training
or uh
drugs
or anything else don't know how to
increase the g factor okay you said a
lot of really interesting things there
so
first i mean just to get people used to
in case they're not familiar with this
idea g factor
is what we mean so often there's a uh
this term used iq
which is
the way i iq is used they really mean g
factor
in regular conversation
the way because we what we mean by iq we
mean intelligence and what we mean by
intelligence we mean general
intelligence and general intelligence in
the human mind from a psychology from a
serious rigorous scientific perspective
actually means g factor so g factor
equals intelligence just in this
conversation to define terms okay so so
there's this stable thing called g
factor you said
now
factor you said factor many times
means
a measure
that's a potential could be reduced to a
single number across the different
factors you mentioned and
uh
what you said it accounts for half
half ish
accounts for half ish of what of
variance across the different
set of tests
so if you're if you do for some reason
well on some set of tests
what does that mean so that that means
there's some unique capabilities outside
of the g factor that might account for
that and what are those
what else is there besides the raw
horsepower the engine inside your mind
that generates intelligence there are
test taking skills
there are
specific abilities
someone might be particularly good
at
mathematical
things mathematical concepts even simple
arithmetic people are some people are
much better than others you might know
people who can memorize and short-term
memory is another uh
component of this
short-term memory is one of the
cognitive processes that's most highly
correlated with the g factor
um
so
so all those things like memory uh taste
test taking skills account for
variability across the the test
performances but you so you can
you can run but you can't hide
from the thing that god gave you the
genetics um
so that g factor
science says that g factor's there each
one of us have
each one of us has a g factor oh boy
some have more than others i'm getting
uncomfortable already well iq is a score
an iq an iq score is a very good
estimate of the g factor you can't
measure g directly there's no direct
measure you estimate it from these
statistical techniques
but an iq score is a good estimate why
because a standard iq test is a battery
of different mental abilities
you combined it into one score
and that score is highly correlated with
the g factor even if you get better
scores on some subtest than others
because again it's what's common to all
these mental abilities so that a good iq
test
i'll ask you about that but a good iq
test
tries to compress down
that battery of tests like tries to get
a nice battery
the nice selection of variable tests
into one test
and so in that way it sneaks up to this
g5 and that's another interesting thing
about g factor
now you give first of all you have a
great book
on the neuroscience of intelligence you
have a great course which is when i
first learned
you're a great teacher let me just thank
you
uh you
your course at the teaching company i
hope i'm saying that correctly the
intelligent brain the intelligent brain
is when i first
heard about this g factor this
mysterious thing that lurks in the
darkness that we cannot quite shine at
light on we're trying to sneak up on
so the fact that there's this measure
stable measure of intelligence we can't
measure directly
but we can come up with a battery test
or one test that includes a battery of
um
variable type of
questions that can
reliably or
attempt to estimate in a stable way that
g factor that's a fascinating idea so
for me as an ai person it's fascinating
it's fascinating there's something
stable like that about the human mind
especially if it's grounded in genetics
it's both
fascinating that
as a researcher of the human mind
and
all the human
[Music]
psychological sociological ethical
questions that start arising it makes me
uncomfortable but truth can be
uncomfortable
you know i i get that a lot about being
uncomfortable talking about this
let me go back and just say one more
empirical thing
it doesn't matter
which battery of tests you use
so there are countless tests you can
take any 12 of them at random
extract a g factor and another 12 at
random and extract a g factor and those
g factors will be highly correlated like
over 0.9 with each other that very so it
is a ubiquitous it doesn't depend on the
content of the test is what i'm trying
to say yes it is general among all those
tests of mental ability and tests of
mental you know mental abilities include
things like geez uh playing poker
your skill at poker is not unrelated to
g
your skill at anything that requires
reasoning and thinking anything from
spelling
arithmetic
more complex things
this concept is ubiquitous and when you
do batteries of tests in different
cultures you get the same thing
so this says something interesting about
the human mind that is a computer is
designed to be
general
so that means you can
[Music]
so it's not
it's not easily made specialized
meaning
if you're going to be good at one thing
uh miyamoto musashi has this quote he's
an ancient warrior
famous for the book of five rings in the
martial arts world and
the quote goes if you know the way
broadly you will see it in everything
meaning if you
do
one thing is going to generalize
to everything
and that that's an interesting thing
about the human mind
so that that's what the g factor
reveals
you